>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
[ Applause ]
>> James Billington:
Good evening everyone.
It's my great pleasure as
Librarian of Congress to welcome you
to this presentation of the John W.
Kluge Prize for Lifetime Achievement
in the Study of Humanity.
This award has been created through
the generosity of John Kluge,
who together with his wonderful
wife, is here with us tonight.
It's for a prize that
we are grateful to him,
but also for much else that he
has done for the nation's library
as the founder and longtime chairman
of its principal private-sector
support group,
many of whose members are here also.
The James Madison Council.
So, John Kluge, on behalf
of all of us, thank you.
[ Applause ]
This prize has been created in the
Library of Congress, so I also want
to thank at the outset, the
many members of Congress
who are here tonight,
especially Representative Ehlers
and Senator Stevens who are the
current chair and vice chair
of the Congress's oldest joint
committee of the two houses,
The Joint Committee on
the Library of Congress.
I also want to thank members
of the Madison Council
who will be meeting tomorrow
under its current distinguished
long longtime friend
of the library, Chairman Ed Cox.
Now, the Kluge Prize is a
unique international award.
It covers all languages, all
cultures and the broad fields
across cultures of the
humanities and social sciences.
Disciplines conspicuously not
included in the Nobel Prizes.
Tonight, we honor John Hope
Franklin, and Yu Ying-Shih,
two scholars who have each produced
an enormous amount of scholarship
and presented it in a
wide variety of formats
to a wide variety of
grateful audiences.
Each of these two has played a
leading and groundbreaking role
in bringing into the mainstream
of scholarship, important
and previously neglected
aspects of the history
of their respective native land.
Moreover, the scholarship of each
has affected both the consciousness
and the conscience of a
broader public in a unique way
in both cultures during the
second half of the 20th century.
They have both seen, in
addition that deep values lodged
at the very core of the respective
cultures, provide a basis
for understanding, correcting
and moving beyond past abuse
and neglect towards a better future.
Our first awardee this
evening is John Hope Franklin,
who has been the leading scholar in
the second half of the 20th century
in establishing African American
history as an inescapably key area
in the study of the American past.
He has been both a pathfinder
and a model for other scholars,
for the broader public, a long
and complex history of race
in this country has been
opened up over the course
of 63 years by this amazing man.
He has produced works
of many different types
and of consistent quality.
He has reached a broader audience
with a celebrated textbook,
a biography, an autobiography,
and his personal leadership
in a lengthy dialogue on race
that ranged all over America
in the final years
of the 20th century.
He has broken all records
in honorary degrees.
If chemists kept track of
this, they would take due note,
and he is currently
emeritus professor of history
at Duke University, which was named
a center for interdisciplinary
and international studies
in his honor.
He provided historical depth
for the argumentation used
in the landmark Supreme
Court ruling of Brown
versus the Board of Education.
And he is an international
as well is a national hero,
having played a leading role
in saving the world-wide Fulbright
Program while he was chairman
of its board during a period
when that programs budgetary
future seemed most endangered.
Dr. Franklin, it is an honor to
confer on you the Kluge Prize
for lifetime achievement
in the study of humanity
and I respectfully request that you
come forward to receive this award.
[ Applause ]
>> John Hope Franklin: Thank
you very much, Dr. Billington.
I'm deeply honored by Mr.
Kluge, Dr. Billington,
and all of my colleagues
whose confidence
in my efforts have
endured to the point
that they supported my
candidacy for this great honor.
That the Library of Congress
played a significant role
in the entire process of
selecting the recipients
and administering the Kluge Award,
is not at all surprising to me.
You see, I have a feeling
that the librarian of Congress
and his staff have
kept a wary eye on me
for the past 67 years [laugther].
I came to the Library of Congress
for the first time in 1939,
with every intention of rewriting
the history of the United States
in a way that would
be palpably inclusive.
It was not easy for a
24-year-old graduate student
to persuade Willard Webb, then
the study room supervisor,
that I qualified for a study
room for whatever I was doing.
I succeeded in persuading
him and almost every morning
for the next several months Mr.
Webb, as he made his rounds,
would stop and have
a few words with me.
He commented that I must be quite
interested in Thomas Jefferson
since I kept his notes
on Virginia on my desk,
and it was frequently open.
So, one day he asked me
if I found it helpful.
And I told him that
it was invaluable
for what I was attempting to do.
And that was to confront the
numerous missed constructions
of the history of the
United States by some
of the most influential
thinkers in our history.
He wondered what role
Jefferson played
in what I was attempting to do.
I merely replied that his negative
influence was enormous [laughter].
Although the average observer did
not see beyond his obvious influence
as a founding father
and as the author
of the Declaration of Independence.
I was not yet prepared to share
with Mr. Webb, or indeed any others,
my view of Jefferson's
enormous influence in arguing
that African-Americans were
inferior to whites in many ways.
Jefferson insisted, for example,
that since Blacks required
less sleep than whites even
after a hard day's work,
they could be induced
by the slightest amusement
to sit up until midnight.
Yet, he continued, since
their existence appeared
to "participate more of sensation
than reflection" they were disposed
to sleep when abstracted from their
diversions or unemployed in labor
like an animal who is at rest.
Thanks to Willard Webb
and his successors,
and thanks to Dr. Billington and his
predecessors, I've been permitted
to explore the wellspring
of American history
from the 17th century
to the present.
Thanks also to the John W.
Kluge Center, I was able,
as one of the first Kluge senior
fellows at the Library of Congress
to explore even more
intensively certain aspects
of recent American history.
Meanwhile, I spent days at a
time, weeks at a time and months
at a time enjoying the resource
of what I call this eighth wonder
of the world, the Library
of Congress.
What I have found, among many other
things, has been a persistent effort
on the part of some
who should know better,
to explain certain
developments in American history
as the inevitable result of using,
say, Africans to play certain roles.
Thus, the Jeffersonian
argument goes as follows.
If a slave works hard under the
lash, he is quick to fall asleep
when the lights no
longer forces them
to perform certain
tasks, remarkable finding.
Further, if he does not manifest
an attachment to a certain way
of doing things, he's likely
to become attached by instinct
to another way of doing things.
Fantastic, even if elementary.
Finally, since "blacks secrete
less by the kidneys and more
by the glands of the skin, they have
a strong and disagreeable odor,"
to which I have added, especially
since in all likelihood they
are worked in the fields
or in the kitchen for 12, or
15 hours, or even more a day
without an opportunity to bathe.
The more I have studied
the history of our country
over the last 70 years, the
clearer it has become to me,
by now I have come to understand
the nature of American society,
and the certainty of
many of its participants
that their own position
is clear and correct.
I have attempted to
re-examine the ideologies
that undergird our system.
I've also struggled to understand
how it is that we seek a land
of freedom for the people of Europe
and at the same time establish
a social and economic system
that enslaved people who
happened not to be from Europe,
or kept in that position.
I've struggled to understand
how it is that we could fight
for independence and,
at the very same time,
use that newly won independence
to enslave many who had joined
in the fight for independence.
As a student of history,
I have attempted
to explain it historically.
But that explanation has not
been at all satisfactory.
That has left me no alternative
but to use my knowledge of history,
and whatever other knowledge and
skills I have, to present the case
for change in keeping
with the express purpose
of attaining the promised goals
of equality for all peoples.
In this way, we can perhaps
realize the goals that grow
out of the tenants to which we claim
to have been committed
from the beginning.
It is a sad fact, that
it was in my generation
that one witnessed the first
African-Americans achieving some
recognition in the
field of scholarship.
Until then, few white Americans,
even those who advocated a measure
of political equality,
subscribe to the view
that African-Americans had the
ability to think, either abstractly
or concurrently, or to
understand and assimilate ideas
that had been formulated by others.
evidence. Much of the
20th century was spent
by African-American
scholars knocking on the door
of American scholarship
and seeking entry.
Only here and there
did the door open,
and all too often it was
opened grudgingly, if at all.
It was this inability to open wide
the door of American scholarship
that caused William E. B.
Du Bois to comment in 1903
on his own intellectual
loneliness when he said,
"I sit with Shakespeare
and he winces not.
Across the color line, I move
arm in arm with Balzac and Dumas,
while smiling men and welcoming
women glide in gilded halls.
From out the caves of evening,
the swing between the strong-limbed
earth and the tracery of starts,
I summon Aristotle and
Aurelius and what soul I will,
and they have come all graciously,
with no scorn, nor or condescension.
So, wed with truth, I
dwell above the veil.
Is this this life you grudge
me, oh nightly America?
Is this the life you long to change
into the dull red hideousness
of Georgia?
Are you so afraid lest peering from
this high Pisgah, between Philistine
and Amalekite, we sight
the promised land?"
But it is not enough merely to cite
the promised land in the distance.
And Du Bois would be the first
to be dissatisfied with
such a modest goal.
He insisted always that the people
from whom he spoke should never
be satisfied with something
so ephemeral as a promised land.
And when he reached the
conclusion that the land
of his birth would never concede
full and equal citizenship for him,
he renounced it, the country, and
denounced it and retreated to Ghana,
where he spent the
remaining few years of life.
But we, who are dissatisfied
with the present condition
in this country, should not
retreat to Ghana or somewhere else.
Nor should we even desire to do so.
Our past is here, our lord is
here, our presence is here.
Our investment of more than
three centuries is here.
Our future is here.
Many years ago, I discovered
that there were various ways
that a historian could utilize
his training and talents
to move this nation closer
to the principles for which
so many have made the
supreme sacrifice to achieve.
So, in 1948 Thurgood
Marshall, the Chief Counsel
for the NAACP legal defense fund,
sought my assistance in breaking
that color barrier at the
University of Kentucky.
A young African-American was seeking
admission to do graduate work
in history at the University
of Kentucky.
When he was denied admission;
surprise, surprise, Marshall sued,
and asked me to serve as an
expert witness in the effort
to establish the fact
that the University
of Kentucky was the only
publicly supported institution
where you could secure
graduate training in history.
Before I could testify
regarding the inadequacy
of Kentucky's historically
black college
in training graduate
students in history,
the federal judge had
ordered the admission
of the African-American
graduate student
to the University of Kentucky.
Even without my public
participation in the argument,
I discovered that my role as
an expert witness could assist
in bringing about change
and equity in our society.
And this will be done without
compromising my scholarship one wit.
Some years later a variation
of the same was true in Brown
versus the Board of
Education, when I discovered
that I could use my training and
my knowledge to assist counsel
in gaining the admission of Linda
Brown and the other plaintiffs
to better schools that were
not segregated in 1954.
Then, some years later,
in 1965 I discovered
in the Selma Montgomery march,
that I could be effective
in joining other historians as well
as crusaders of various stripes
in marching and working together
to impress high and arrogant powers
and to relent in their extreme
and excessive use of racial
and social bigotry in their
effort to maintain the status quo.
I've been most fortunate in having
the opportunity to participate
in an exciting and rewarding
educational experience
over the past three
quarters of a century.
At the same time, I've been able to
witness the partial transformation
of our society into
something more in keeping
with the expressed aspirations
of our founding fathers.
I have been most fortunate in
having the support of scholars
and colleagues in many parts of
the country and of the world.
I can only hope that my work
will be a part of the legacy,
not only of my students, and others
who find it possible that we can,
under certain circumstances,
do something that's
effective and supportable.
But I also hope that one can find
something valuable in my words,
but also those who have found
some validation of their own work
in what I have tried to say and do.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> James Billington: Your applause
speaks louder than any words could
in saying thank you,
John Hope Franklin.
Our second awardee, Yu Ying-Shih,
has been described by his peers
as the most widely read contemporary
historian writing in Chinese.
And these are quotes, "The greatest
Chinese intellectual historian
of our generation.
Working deeply with original text,
he has rescued rich
Confucian heritage,
and much else in Chinese culture,
its ancient and rich culture
from caricature neglect
and has even beginning
with the original text following
Confucian thought in its own right,
and its interaction with
other elements of Chinese."
And indeed, later of Western
thought and his experience.
So, that he's really covered the
entire multi-millennial history
and range of Chinese
thought and experience.
His scholarship has reached
across many disciplines,
time periods and issues.
Examined in a profound way, major
questions and deeper truths,
not only about Chinese
culture but about human nature.
And has brought in, in his half a
century of teaching in this country,
brought in elements and an
understanding of this rich heritage
that is quite remarkable.
Although, perhaps not as yet
fully discovered because most
of his most important writing is
still available only in Chinese.
But how widely available, more
than 30 books, which spanned more
than 2000 years of history.
He has stimulated younger
scholars to rediscover,
not just the richness,
but the variety
of Chinese intellectual tradition.
Something which has been
seriously lost during the period
of the so-called cultural
Revolution in China.
His work is widely read
and discussed throughout the
Chinese speaking world as much
on the mainland as in Hong Kong,
Taiwan and other parts of East Asia.
It's been translated into many of
the other languages of East Asia.
He has had four university
professorships at Michigan, Harvard,
Yale, and then mostly at Princeton
where he is the emeritus professor
of history and has been so, has
been teaching for nearly 2 decades.
It gives me great pleasure
both to be honoring one
of the world's most ancient
cultures, and one of its most modern
and forward-looking minds,
someone who has made a contribution
to the intellectual
traditions of China,
the kind of great awakening
contribution
that John Hope Franklin has
made to our own culture.
It gives me great pleasure to
ask Professor Yu to come forward
to accept the John W. Kluge Award.
[ Applause ]
>> Yu Ying-Shih: Thank
you very much,
Dr. Billington for your kind words.
I feel enormously honored
to be a co-recipient
of the John W. Kluge Prize in
2006, for which I am grateful.
After much reflection, however,
I have come to the realization
that the main justification
for my presence here tonight is
that both the Chinese
cultural tradition
and Chinese intellectual history
as a discipline are
being honored through me.
The former has been the subject
of my lifetime scholarly pursuit,
and the latter my chosen
field of specialization.
When I first became seriously
interested in the study
of Chinese history and
culture in the 1940s,
the Chinese historical
mind happened to be cast
in an anti-traditionalistic mold.
The Chinese past as a whole,
was viewed negatively,
and whatever appeared to be
uniquely Chinese was interpreted
as a deviation from the norm
of civilization's progress
as exemplified in the historical
development of the West.
Needless to say, I
was at a complete loss
as to the Chinese cultural
identity, and for that matter,
also my personal identity.
It was my good fortune that I was
able to finish my college education
in Hong Kong and pursued
my graduate studies
in the United States,
now my adopted country.
As my intellectual horizon
gradually widened over the years,
the truth was beginning
to dawn on me
that the Chinese culture
must be clearly recognized
as an indigenous tradition with
characteristics distinctly its own.
The crystallization
of Chinese culture
into its definitive shape
took place in the time
of Confucius a crucial moment in
the ancient world better known
in the West as the Axial Age.
During this period, it has been
observed, a spiritual awakening
or breakthrough occurred in
several highly-developed cultures
in the ancient world
including China, India,
Persia, Israel, and Greece.
It took the form of either
philosophical reasoning
or post-mythical religious
imagination or, as in the case
of China, a mixed type
of moral, philosophic
and religious consciousness.
The awakening led directly to
the emergence of the dichotomy
between the actual world
and the world beyond.
The world beyond as a new vision,
provided the thinking individuals,
be they philosophers,
prophets or sages
with the necessary
transcending point
from which the actual world
could be examined and questioned;
critically as well as reflectively.
This is generally known
as the original transcendence
of the Axial Age.
As a result of the Chinese
original transcendence in the time
of Confucius, the all-important
idea of Tao emerged as a symbol
of the world beyond vis-a-vis the
actual world of everyday life.
But the Chinese transcendental
world of Tao and the actual world
of everyday life were conceived from
the very beginning to be related
to each other in a way different
from other ancient cultures
undergoing the Axial breakthrough.
For example, there is nothing in the
early Chinese philosophical visions
that suggests Plato's conception
of an unseen eternal world
of which the actual world
is only a pale copy.
In the religious tradition, the
world of God and the world of humans
as demonstrated in the
Christian type, is also absent.
Nor, do we find in classical Chinese
thought, in all its varieties,
anything that closely resembles the
radical negativity of early Buddhism
with its insistence
on the un-realness
and worthlessness of this world.
By contrast, the world
of Tao was not perceived
as very far from the human world.
As best expressed by Confucius,
"The Tao is not far from man.
When a man pursues the Tao
and remains away from man,
his course cannot be
considered the Tao."
The notion of Tao was also
shared by all the major thinkers
in the Chinese Axial Age, including
Lao Tzu, Mo Tzu and Chuang Tzu.
It was their common belief
that Tao is hidden and
yet functions everywhere in the
human world; even men and women
of simple intelligence can know
and practice it in everyday life
to a larger or lesser degree.
Indeed, judging from
the ever-growing
and deepening influences of the
ideas originating in the Axial Age,
especially Confucian and
Taoist ideas, on all aspects
of Chinese life down
through the centuries.
It may not be too much an
exaggeration to suggest that Tao
and history constitute the inside
and the outside of
Chinese civilization.
Taking the Chinese cultural
tradition to be essentially one
of indigenous tradition
and independent growth,
I have tried over the decades
to study Chinese history
along two main lines.
First, the Chinese culture must
be understood in its own terms,
but at the time also in a
comparative perspective.
By comparative perspective, I
refer to both Indian Buddhism
in the early imperial period
and Western culture
since the 16th century.
Since the beginning
of the 20th century,
the Chinese mind has been largely
preoccupied with the problematique
of China-versus-the-West.
To interpret the Chinese
past solely in its own terms
without a comparative perspective
would certainly run the risk
of falling into the age-old
trap of Sino centrism.
Second, in my study of Chinese
history from classical antiquity
to the 20th century, my focus
has always been placed on periods
of change when one historical
stage moved to the next.
Compared to other civilizations,
China's is particularly marked
by its long historical continuity.
But continuity and change went
hand-in-hand in Chinese history.
Therefore, the purpose I
have set myself is twofold.
Firstly, to identify
the major intellectual,
social and culture changes
in the Chinese past.
And, secondly, to discern if at
all possible, the unique pattern
of Chinese historical changes.
More often than not, such
broad and profound changes
in Chinese history transcended the
rise and the fall of dynasties.
Thus, the notion of dynastic cycle,
long held in traditional China,
but also briefly in vogue in
the West, is highly misleading.
In the early years of the 20th
century, Chinese historians began
to reconstruct and re-interpret
the Chinese past according
to the historical model of the West.
Since then, it has
been generally assumed
that China must have
undergone similar stages
of historical development as
shown in European history.
In the first half of
the 20th century,
Chinese historians adopted
the earlier European schemes
of periodization by dividing
Chinese history into ancient,
medieval and modern periods.
This has been replaced since 1949
by the Marxist-Stalinist
five-stage formulation.
The latter remains the orthodox
in China up to this day,
at least in theory if
not always in practice.
This Procrustean approach, whatever
merits it may have otherwise,
cannot possibly do full
justice to Chinese culture
as an indigenous tradition.
Only by focusing on the
unique course and shape
of Chinese historical
changes, I am convinced,
can we hope to see more clearly how
that great cultural tradition moved
from stage to stage driven,
mainly if not entirely,
by its internal dynamics.
Now, let me turn to the question
of how, as two different systems
of values, does Chinese culture
stand vis-a-vis Western culture
in historical perspective?
My earliest exposure to this
question occurred in the late 1940s
when the problematique of China
versus-the-West, mentioned earlier,
dominated the Chinese
intellectual world.
It has not been out of my
consciousness ever since.
Living in the United
States for half a century,
the question has acquired a truly
existential meaning for my life
as I move between the two
cultures from moment to moment.
With some initial psychological
readjustments, I have long been able
to enjoy the American way
of life while still retaining
my Chinese cultural identity.
However, the best guide with regard
to whether Chinese culture is
compatible with the core values
of the West can only be
provided by Chinese history.
China first encountered the modern
West at the end of the 16th century
when the Jesuits came to do their
missionary work in East Asia.
The culturally sensitive Matteo
Ricci was very quick to discover
that the Chinese religious
atmosphere
at that time was highly
tolerant; Confucianism, Buddhism
and Taoism were generally
regarded as one and the same thing.
It was this period of religious
tolerance that accounted
for Ricci's extraordinary
success in his conversion
of many leading members
of the Confucian elite.
The Confucian faith in
the sameness of human mind
and the universal accessibility
of Tao
to every human person anywhere
led some Chinese converts
to promote a synthesis of
Christianity with Confucianism.
The Chinese Tao was now further
expanded to include Christianity.
In the late 19th century, it was
also the open-minded Confucians
who enthusiastically embraced values
and ideas dominant
in the modern West.
Such as democracy, liberty,
equality, rule of law,
autonomy of the individual person,
and, above all, human rights.
When some of them visited Europe
or America for the first time
and stayed there long enough to
make first-hand observations,
they were all deeply impressed,
first of all, by the ideals
and institutions of Western
constitutional democracy.
At the turn of the century, there
were two rival Confucian schools
in China known as the New Text
and the Old Text, respectively.
Both advocated democracy and
jointly began a systematic search
for the origins and the
evolution of democratic ideas
in early Confucian texts.
In so doing, it is clear that
they took the compatibility
between Chinese culture
and Western culture
as two systems of values
for granted.
Last but not least, I wish to
say a word about human rights.
Like democracy, human rights as
a term is linguistically specific
to the West and nonexistent in
traditional Confucian discourse.
However, if we agree that the
concept of human rights as defined
in the United Nations'
Universal Declaration of 1948,
is predicated on the
double recognition
of a common humanity
and human dignity.
Then we are also justified to speak
of a Confucian idea of human rights
without the Western terminology.
Recognition of common
humanity and respect
for human dignity are both clearly
articulated in the Analects,
Mencius and other early texts.
It is remarkable that by the first
century Common Era, at the latest,
the Confucian notion of human
dignity was openly referred
to in imperial decrees as sufficient
grounds for the prohibition
of the sale or killing of slaves.
Both imperial decrees, dated 9
and 35 Common Era, respectively,
cited the same famous
Confucian dictum,
"Of all living things
produced by Heaven and Earth,
the human person is the noblest."
Slavery as an institution
was never accepted
by Confucianism as legitimate.
It was the Confucian humanism that
predisposed late Ch'ing Confucians
to be so readily appreciative
of the Western theory
and practice of human rights.
If history is any guide, then
there seems to be a great deal
of overlapping consensus
in basic values
between Chinese culture
and Western culture.
After all, recognition
of common humanity
and human dignity is what the
Chinese Tao has been about.
I am more convinced than ever
that once Chinese culture returns
to the main flow of
Tao, the problematique
of China-versus-the-West
will also come to an end.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> James Billington: Thank
you very much, Professor Yu.
We will print and mail to
each of you, in the audience,
the full text of both Dr.
Franklin's and Dr. Yu's remarks
so that you may read and re-read
them later at your leisure.
I must say you've sent us with
these reflections over a long period
of time into a higher realm.
And we're about to go into another
realm in the universal language
of music as we welcome the
president of the Curtis Institute,
Roberto Diaz, and the Curtis gifted
students from that Curtis Institute
who will perform tonight.
And we also welcome Gerry Lenfest
who made tonight's performance
by the Curtis students possible.
Gerry has been a great supporter
of the library, member of this
from 15 years of this
Madison Council
to which I've already
spoken is also Chairman
of the Curtis Institute's
board of trustees.
And both the library and the
Curtis Institute owe much
of their musical legacy, the place
we are in tonight, to the generosity
and commitment of extraordinary
women patrons.
Mary Louise Curtis Bok established
the Curtis Institute in 1924.
Later set up an endowment to pay
in full tuition expense
for all Curtis students.
Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge in
1925 paid for the construction
of this hall, set up an endowment
to support free public concerts
and commissions which
continue to this day.
And Gertrude Clark Whittall
10 years later donated the set
of Stradivarius instruments that the
Curtis musicians will play tonight.
And also provided an endowment to
have them perpetually maintained
and specifically performed
in concerts.
So, we're grateful to the Curtis
Institute for helping us be faithful
to this bequest by playing
the Stradivarius instruments
that you will here shortly.
I should say that Curtis also
trained many young composers
who then went on to receive Library
of Congress musical commissions,
whose works were premiered
here in this hall.
First performance ever
of Aaron Copland's
"Appalachian Spring" was commission
by the library and performed here.
And also, their distinguished
graduates
and friends have many personal
collections now residing
in the library.
The collections of Samuel
Barber and Leonard Bernstein,
whose music will be
performed tonight.
Manuscripts by Lukas Foss, Gian
Carlo Menotti, and Ned Rorem,
many others have found their
way to the Library of Congress
to ride alongside original
manuscripts we have of Bach, Mozart,
Beethoven, Brahms,
Stravinsky, and many others.
So, we welcome this opportunity
to further our connection
to the Curtis Institute, its leaders
and its talented students
during tonight's performance.
And we thank, once again,
the Kluge Center honorees,
the Kluge Prize winners for lifting
up our hearts, our imaginations,
and the continuing struggle
to understand in a context
that is moral, rather
than just moralistic,
and that it goes ever deeper into
the common study of humanity,
which we try to celebrate
in the Kluge Center,
which is just upstairs here.
So, I thank Gerry Lenfest and
the Curtis Institute for coming
and we look forward to hearing
from these talented performers
who will bring to you the music
on Stradivarius instruments
with which they have
fallen, I gather,
in love in the few
days of performance.
So, we share that love with you.
We thank you, and we look
forward to lifting our hearts
with the sounds of music.
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]
I won't hold up the progress
for dinner, but before we leave,
we not only have thanked
these marvelous artists,
but I want to make two quick
presentations, to Roberto Diaz,
the Curtis Institute and
the chairmen of its board,
Gerry Lenfest, for bringing
these amazing artists to us.
These are facsimiles of two of the
most cherished American compositions
of the 20th century,
of which we happen
to be the custodians
here at the library.
Barber's Adagio for Mr. Diaz is in
charge of these wonderful artists
who brought them to this and has
made this whole thing possible,
[inaudible] for Gerry Lenfest.
So, here we are thank you all.
[ Applause ]
And we now proceed with thanks
once again to the musicians,
and praise once again for the Kluge
Prize winners this year upstairs,
now up for dinner on the Mezzanine
floor, which is two floors up.
We look forward to seeing you there
and continuing this
evening's celebration.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.